[SIDE CONVERSATION]
AUDIENCE: Before, we
have been [INAUDIBLE]..
MODERATOR: Should we
wait or should we start?
BRENDAN JUBA: It's up to you.
What do you feel like?
Do you think they're
going to come down?
MODERATOR: [INAUDIBLE].
MODERATOR: We'll start.
BRENDAN JUBA: Start now?
That's fine.
AUDIENCE: Where is it?
MODERATOR: OK, welcome back.
So next up, we'll hear
from the [INAUDIBLE]
complexity folks about
Skolem function counter.
Brendan?
BRENDAN JUBA: Thank you.
Welcome back after lunch.
Hopefully, this won't
tax you too much.
So this is joint work with a
Arijit Shaw and Kuldeep Meel.
Arijit is the graduate student
who did most of the real work
on this.
And so when we were--
after we did this work,
Kuldeep and I were talking about
how should we present this.
And Kuldeep had a vision for
how this was going to go,
and it went a little
something like this.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[STAR WARS MUSIC]
[LAUGHTER]
MODERATOR: [INAUDIBLE].
BRENDAN JUBA: I don't
know they can hear it.
I don't know if they
can hear it on Zoom.
So to be fair, I
wouldn't necessarily
have presented it
this way, but I
wanted to remain
as true as possible
to Kuldeep's original vision.
I hope you all feel
very motivated now.
[END PLAYBACK]
So a little bit
more dryly, here's
what the problem actually is.
So yeah, professor,
what's a Skolem function?
So you've got a
first order sentence.
So this is a Boolean formula.
My variables are all quantified.
I have two types of
quantifiers for all and exists,
and I'd really rather
just have one of them.
So in particular,
let's suppose I
want to get rid of these
existential quantifiers
so that I'm just dealing
with some sort of--
I just want something
that's a true statement
irrespective of then the
binding of the remaining
free variables.
And so a Skolemization
is where you're
going to replace those
existentially bound variables
with functions of variables
that were previously bound,
which are basically going
to capture what would be
a successful binding of those
variables given the things that
were previously bound
outside in that scope.
And those-- so it eliminates
the existentials, and those
are called Skolem functions.
So to be precise--
and it actually matters here--
so if I have this first order
Boolean sentence-- and let's
suppose the body here could
be another Boolean sentence
on more variables.
If I have a function
that takes that, say,
one existentially bound
variable and maps it--
again, given a setting of the
previously bound variables--
to something that preserves the
truth value of the sentence,
then that's a Skolem function.
And again, I'm saying
preserves the truth value
because if the sentence was
not true to begin with--
if there was some binding of
w for which there was no x,
this thing would have been
false, and you might say,
well, there's no
Skolem function.
In this case, we're
going to let that just
be an arbitrary binding
of the variable.
So it's always going to exist.
In some cases, it
might be that it
doesn't matter what the function
value is for that binding of w.
We're happy with anything.
And so very broad strokes--
the problem that
we're considering here
is to count the number of
Skolem functions for a formula
now that actually--
this is just going
to be a propositional
formula, so I just
have a single alternation.
And to make things
relatively simple,
all the domains are just
going to be Boolean.
So n bits, m bits.
Yeah, so it's a--
so from a very general
problem to a much simpler one.
What's that?
(INCREDULOUS) You think
this is just a problem
that we just made up?
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[END PLAYBACK]
So what is it good for?
So here's one possible
application of this.
So in system security,
a natural technique
is randomization
of your components.
And traditionally, the way
this is done is by, say,
taking the code and
applying some sort
of a transformation on it
that preserves the semantics.
A very common thing is like
address space randomization
to try to make it hard to
clobber important values
in your memory.
A slightly different take
on it that we have here is,
let's suppose that we have a
specification for the function.
Now, if I look at
this sentence--
so for all inputs,
there is an output
meeting the specification--
the Skolem count
for that sentence
is the number of
possible functions
that satisfy the specification.
And so if I had a
large count that's
telling me that somehow many
possible implementations
of this specification
are possible-- and so
then there's some scope for
being able to get something out
of randomizing over which
implementation you use.
Furthermore, using a reduction
of approximate sampling
to approximate
counting, it would
be possible to simulate the
evaluation of a random function
meeting that specification at
some points of your choice.
Now, I'm not going to claim
that this is really fast.
I wouldn't actually want
to use a system that
was built on top of this,
but it's at least telling you
that you might be
able to use this
for some kind of prototyping.
See how it works.
A second application would
be modeling uncertainty
of player strategies.
So again, let's suppose that
I have a formula indicating
if x is a good response to some
game state or initial move w.
Then, a random Skolem function
is a maximum entropy good
response strategy.
And so I can try to
use that as a model of,
what are the possible strategies
that an opponent could
be using in this game?
And then the Skolem
count, in turn,
is giving you the entropy
of those strategies.
So these applications
are a little bit made up.
And the third
application is I would
like to hear from you if you can
think of any more applications
for this problem, because
it is a new problem.
So having seen this and
having been in these workshops
all week, you might
immediately wonder,
is this just first
order model accounting?
Like, I could
write this sentence
so this part is
just propositional,
and there's one
relation here, f.
And if I look at this formula
with this existential counting
quantifier--
yeah, so models
for this relation f
correspond to a Skolem function.
And this is a first-order
sentence with two variables.
It's in that fragment
that we can solve.
What's the problem?
And the problem is tractable
for a first-order model
counting means polynomial
in the domain size.
But in these cases,
we have m bits,
and so we end up with some sort
of a relatively large domain.
So it's not exactly
tractable, so we need
we do need other techniques.
But the problem is
still a little bit hard,
so we changed things
a little bit more.
It's immediate that exact
counting is #P-hard.
Propositional model
counting is a special case.
And so there's two
answers to this.
One is we're going to
consider, of course,
randomized approximate counting.
But moreover, we're also
going to need to use oracles
for these subroutines
of model counting
and approximate sampling.
We're not going to use too
many model counting queries.
Ultimately, it will
be two, but the number
of these queries that we
use is, in some sense,
going to be the main complexity
measure for this thing.
Now, the other problem
here is the number
of possible functions is
potentially very large,
and I can't even
write down a number
that's this large in some
reasonable amount of time.
And yeah, so the answer
here is, well, we're
going to just work with the
log of the number of Skolem
functions.
And in cases where
maybe I was interested
in the entropy of that
distribution, then
this is basically
what I want anyway.
It's still, again, not a problem
that is immediately obvious how
to tackle in a scalable way.
So the main results
that we have are
that we get an approx--
multiplicative approximate
count of the log of the
number of Skolem functions
given some polynomial number of
calls to approximate sampling
and counting oracles, and two
calls to an exact #SAT oracle.
And in these
experiments, we will
see that it scales much better
than a totally naive baseline.
Firstly, I hope that this is not
the last word on the problem,
and we'll come back
to some, hopefully,
potential ways it can
be improved later.
But our method is based
on the following three
key observations.
The first is that the count
factorizes with respect
to the input.
I can set the value of f for
the different w's independently.
And so in particular, when
I look at the log count,
this is just a big sum of the
log counts for each possible
binding of those
universal variables w's.
Now second, we can partition the
domain into the following three
pieces, ones where there was no
response for the x variables,
ones where there's a unique
x that satisfies the formula,
and ones where
there's at least two.
And those first two pieces
have really specific counts
for the number of x's.
Here, any x binding will work.
Here, there's a unique one.
And when I look at the log--
so yeah, that's
just m and that's 0.
And for this last
piece, what's nice
is that after I look
at the log, the number
of possible responses lies
somewhere in this range 1 to m,
and that's going to ensure that
I can approximate it easily.
So with this framework
now, the algorithm
is actually pretty
straightforward.
So first of all, we're just
going to directly count
those inputs that don't have
a response x, and that's
just going to be with
[INAUDIBLE] SAT oracle.
That's one of our calls.
Now, the body of it
is actually going
to be estimating this
contribution from those w's
that had more than two, or
at least two, responses.
So first I'm going to count
the number of w's that
had at least two responses.
That's my second call.
And I'm going to
invoke it on just
counting with respect to w.
So this is a projected
model count for this formula
that captures that, yeah, there
were two distinct x responses.
So obviously, this
is satisfiable
if, and only if, you're
in this set for w.
And so then what I do now is--
now we're going to be
sampling universal variables
approximately
uniformly at random
by invoking our
approximate sampling
oracle on this formula.
And then we're going to use
the approximate counting
oracle for that w then to
approximate the count once,
I've fixed w in here, of the
number of possible x responses.
And I'm just going to take
a running count of that
rescaled appropriately
from the number of samples
that I take ultimately up to the
actual number of these things
that have at least
two solutions.
And so then yeah,
my final estimate
is just the pieces that had a
unique solution contribute 0
to the log count, so
this contributes m.
And then this is my thing
that I got by sampling.
And in order to get a 1
plus epsilon multiplicative
approximation, because this log
count was in this range 1 to m,
I only need this polynomial
number of samples.
So it's not that
complicated, I hope.
Let me-- are there any
questions about why this works?
No?
AUDIENCE: In fact, you
only need a linear number
of proximal oracle [INAUDIBLE].
BRENDAN JUBA: That's right.
So anyway, that's
about all I have
to say about this
theoretically right now.
So onward-- implementation
experiments.
So there's an
important optimization.
Rather than just taking
a fixed size sample
that you would get from,
say, the Chernoff bound,
there was an algorithm
from Dagum et al
that adaptively chooses
a number of samples.
And it's giving us
the same guarantee
as if we had used a Chernoff
bound with a fixed size sample,
but you're using fewer runs of
that approximate model counting
oracle sampling
and model counting,
and of course, that's really
important in practice.
So that's not our work.
So anyway, just we use it.
And then we use, again, some
recent state of the art systems
for the various components.
And now, the naive baseline that
we're going to compare against.
Like, really, this is the first
work to study this problem,
so we didn't really
have a good baseline.
So it kind of does
the naive thing.
Everything is just
exact counting.
I'm just enumerating
those w's that have
two distinct solutions, and I
do the exact count for them.
And obviously, this blows up.
So I guess it's a strawman, but
then again, what else is there?
And so, yeah, there's some
state of the art tools
for the enumeration count.
So we have two types of
benchmarks that we look at.
One is to examine the
efficiency and scaling,
and these are basically
benchmarks from works
on Skolem synthesis.
So it's these
[? QBF ?] benchmarks.
Now, it's going to turn out
that the baseline that we
have for getting those
exact counts really sucks.
So we also want
to do experiments
to check the
accuracy in practice,
so we need some really
easy benchmarks.
And so we use this 158 instances
that in particular have
very small input
sizes, and so where
the exact count can succeed.
So yeah, I mean, the story
for scaling is fairly simple.
Out of the 608 instances,
the naive baseline solves 8.
There's the plot of
the running time.
And this new method
solves 379 out of the 608.
So obviously, it's
not everything,
but there's a big
improvement from actually
just literally enumerating all
of the possible w's and doing
this [INAUDIBLE] count.
And if I look at, well,
how long would it take--
look at the number
of counter calls
that would have been invoked
to solve these instances--
yeah, it's a very large
number of exact count calls.
So it's somewhat
implausible that you
would be able to do
this without doing
some kind of a sampling style
reduction in the [INAUDIBLE]..
So for accuracy, just
to stress the point,
the exact thing could only
solve 8 of those 608 instances,
and that's not enough to get a
good measure of the accuracy,
so we use the other 158.
And we're going to run
this thing with our epsilon
parameter being 0.8.
So the guarantee just
says that the count
should lie between 1/5 and
1.8 times the true log count.
So that's what this upper
and lower bound is--
what's 0.8, what's 1/5.
And so the actual
counts look like this.
And so some statistics on
the relative error here.
So the mean relative
error was about a fifth,
so that's significantly better
than a relative error of 0.8.
And out of the 158 benchmarks,
the largest relative error
was less than a half.
So it does seem like it's
substantially outperforming
the guarantee that we have.
Questions about this?
AUDIENCE: You seem
not happy that I
would want to ask you, but--
BRENDAN JUBA: No,
I'm very happy.
I thought that
everybody was just going
to be hibernating after lunch.
AUDIENCE: So given that we
all [INAUDIBLE] circuits,
if the thing under
your quantifiers
is something that
[INAUDIBLE] do you
have [INAUDIBLE] for
this Skolem count?
If every oracle call
is linear time--
BRENDAN JUBA: Yeah.
So I guess--
I mean, the real question--
well, let me come back to this
in like 30 seconds, because
this is my first open question.
It's related to it--
[? made ?] my first
and my second.
So we introduced this new
problem of approximate counting
of Skolem functions.
And we proposed a
randomized algorithm
for a guaranteed
multiplicative approximation
to the log number of functions.
We use the oracle for
exact counting twice,
and this linear number of calls
to the approximate sampling
and counting oracle.
We managed to get 379 out
of 608 of these benchmarks,
and we did outperform the
theoretical relative error
guarantee on these
158 easy instances.
I don't know how good we're
doing on the 608 instances
because we can't
solve them exactly.
But it seems plausible
that this method
or maybe some future
method along this line
could be useful in practice
for these problems.
And again, just to stress,
counting models seemed hard,
but people worked on it.
Synthesizing Skolem
functions seemed hard--
people worked at it.
Counting Skolem functions
seems outrageous,
because I can't even write
down most Skolem functions.
They're just too big.
But nevertheless,
we are actually
able to get some what seem to be
plausibly useful approximations
to that count.
And so I think, really,
nobody thought about-- nobody
dared to consider
what if I could
solve this problem before.
And that's the reason for the
[HUMMING STAR WARS THEME SONG]..
So question-- so first of
all, is that exact model
counting necessary?
I used it twice.
I don't think I really need
it for the second time,
but for the first
one, what I actually
wanted a good guarantee
for is the number
of universal bindings for which
there's no existential binding.
We-- the naive way
to do this-- you
would like to just
negate that formula.
But if you started out saying,
well, I have-- whatever--
DNF, and so I have
my FPRAS for DNF,
let's say, and then
I'm negating that,
then I don't know that I'm
getting my same nice relative
multiplicative error guarantee.
Maybe if-- so you have
another representation here,
your [? DDNF ?] or whatever.
And if you can get the
FPRAS for the count,
and you can say push through
that negation, then hopefully,
you can just get rid of the need
for the exact model counting
and, indeed, get an FPRAS.
So I hope that's true.
My question is really,
do I need it at all,
or how broadly do I need-- do
I actually need the exact model
counting oracle, because
that seems to be the main,
at least to me, barrier
to getting the FPRAS.
The other thing, which
you might be enticed by,
is we have many calls to this
approximate sample and count
oracle on the same formula.
This just sort of screams for
some kind of either compilation
or reuse across the
different iterations.
How can you exploit this?
Kuldeep had some
motivation for extending
to more general
problems of counting
uninterpreted functions in SMT.
I do not feel qualified to
talk about this further.
And finally, yeah, I
mean, I am interested
in other applications.
So we're daring to ask
the question, what if we
could count Skolem functions?
Like, what can you do?
It's like, please put on
your science fiction hat.
And yeah, your questions
for me go here.
MODERATOR:
[INAUDIBLE] questions?
BRENDAN JUBA: We have
ample time for questions.
MODERATOR: Does the count tell
you something about how hard
the [INAUDIBLE]?
It's not clear that-- because--
BRENDAN JUBA: I
don't [INAUDIBLE]----
AUDIENCE: --you
don't want to-- you
want to find a small
representation of a function,
right?
So you don't--
BRENDAN JUBA: Well, yeah.
So it's not going to tell
you much about the synthesis
problem, because the vast--
assuming that it's not unique--
and if it's unique, it's
actually an easy problem.
But assuming that it's not
unique or extremely not unique,
then yeah, most
of these instances
are just not things
that you can write down.
So most of them are completely
irrelevant from the standpoint
of efficient synthesis.
MODERATOR: I'll keep
asking questions.
So if the thing
under the quantifiers
is something that has this--
so this is an arbitrary
propositional formula, right?
BRENDAN JUBA: Mhm.
MODERATOR: But if it's
something with symmetries,
like in the first-order
model counting then,
I guess things also
become easier, or--
BRENDAN JUBA: Should
because-- yeah, I mean, maybe
you can factorize things
further and then just solve
the individual pieces
and then rescale.
AUDIENCE: So thinking about
your second question, what kind
of information do
you think would
be useful to say
between different calls
to sampler counter?
BRENDAN JUBA: Well, I mean--
so for example, just by
analogy to my SAT solving,
I know that if I have these
derived clauses that I could
potentially share across runs.
And I guess it's legitimate to
ask, is there some analogous
thing that I could or
should be sharing for these,
say, approximate counting--
I took these samples,
I did this count,
but maybe I can
back up to something
with some free variables
in it and then resample
those variables or something.
I don't know.
I really don't know.
I mean, it's--
[INAUDIBLE] question
[INAUDIBLE]..
MODERATOR: The final question--
it's not--
BRENDAN JUBA: The balance of
my time goes to [INAUDIBLE]..
MODERATOR: Yeah,
[INAUDIBLE] you can
get to talk for an
extra five minutes.
[CHUCKLES] Thank you, Brendan.
[APPLAUSE]
[SIDE CONVERSATION]